vous avez des protestations contre le
matin des arméniens aujourd'hui 150
presque pareil on a des paroles mairie
on a les arrache la cia merci mais ça tu
pars est-ce qu'on va arrêter de faire
massacrer
[Applaudissements]
nous manifestons contre finit pas ce
n'est pas possible
alors oui c'est le créditeur s'agace
l'école nicole c'est le dialogue
les gosses c'est la négociation normale
qui compte de huit
bien sûr mais ça c'est michel jour sa
série 7 jours heureux nos soldats sont
fait sentir qu a atterri il résiste mais
contre les forces aériennes montrent une
grosse panique à ne rien faire et la
sélection pour parler village pour les
jours pour que les arméniens jour est la
patrie mère dans leur maison et dans
leur appartement
c'est faire ça
[Applaudissements]
alors oui nous voulons une intervention
terrestre
le format 16 10ème tour plat qui adore
la cei vient coiffer à la soeur de jean
et la sortie il met dehors et qui
agissent ils n'ont rien à faire là bas
ces dynasties vallandry nous sommes là
pour te demander à jeudi à la haye aux
parlementaires à le sénateur jean-claude
on est je veux vous le dire on est là
c'est le 13 octobre on pourra pas dire
son salaire on craque donc on va pas
dire qu'on sadefa effectivement le
rapport des forces étaient inégales on
ne pourra pas dire qu'on n'avait pas vu
errer sans experte sûrs qu'ils sont ali
dégagé les chefs de la mairie pour qu'on
domaine le contrôle des opérations vite
on pourra pas dire qu'on ne savait pas
que les servettiens utilisent des
centaines et des centaines de grosses
qualités à aller retour à paris on
savait alors nous
sais pas mais c'est hugo lemaire il faut
laisser j'ai du gouvernement français
qu'il en soit cette imposition
il faut exiger du clan français
il connaît maintenant
devrait-on
l'état grec
[Applaudissements]
et ça
le prêt
[Applaudissements]
m
en vain
c'est bien
certes à lui on en fait le cerveau si on
en fait tous sens fort du terme en nous
lâchons jamais les armées du monde a
changé
les arrêts
elie hallassou
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
voilà
j'ai des amis
bonsoir et merci à tous d'être venus si
nombreux
votre présence si massive non que vous
avez pris la mesure des jauges pigeons
en compte aujourd'hui comme vient de moi
patients le co président du ccn la vie
est aujourd'hui un tournant de
l'histoire un moment crucial de son
destin oui c'est vrai
chanson après un génocide de 1915 les
forces qui avait été mis en branle à
l'époque pour exterminer le peuple
arménien jaujourd'hui à nouveau à la
même heure et c'est la turquie quel
autre sauf après le nouveau site ou bien
qui ont lieu
demander pardon qui occupent s'excuser
qui au lieu de tirer les leçons de ce
pilot minable comme l'allemagne l'a fait
un choix non seulement ne se repentit
fin d'exercice et s'il est bien pour
continuer le travail c'est la guerre qui
sont en train de donner par interviews
interposées
parce que bien sûr erdogan et agnès
constitue une belle patrie et
poursuivent les mêmes objectifs les
objectifs
c'est la fusion du vôtre portions et
cette fusion du bosphore turc
ils veulent la faire sur le dos dans la
rue ni sur le vaudou au canada ce que
deux députés doivent bien comprendre ce
que nos dirigeants doivent bien
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est le haut
karabagh est un verrou stratégique
si le verrou stratégique pour demain le
verrou suivant ce sera l'arménie qui
tombera comme un domino et ensuite vous
serez nous serons l'europe sera
confronté un continuum portions et des
indices parce que j'ai un local et
logiciels sont des stratèges ils ont une
vision
il savait une bombe est ce que nous
momo ici sauf que nos soldats des
comptes avec un héroïsme exceptionnelle
avec la dernière énergie est d'ores et
déjà ils ont gagné dans son rapport de
force inégal entre 900 l'opposition
celui des ports est heureuse bien sûr
mais ce chiffre est content c'est nous
ce sont de belles c'est nassimah si
c'est notre civilisation permet de
vieillir mais que vaut le surnom qu'elle
recherchait un homme mort dans ces
églises en renvoyant une set-list
bombarder les arméniens en bombardant
les populations civiles sont restés
pallenberg que votre fils
si celui ci se décrit un client ou
autres pas donner la couleur et le
parfum de la personne 1 ce qui est en
train de se passer nous nous devons
convertir personnes d'autres religions
nous ne vendons rien nous demandons
simplement un vibrant faire environ
pêche le territoire infinera s'y livre à
choisir nous mêmes notre destin nous
allons construire avec une magnifique
révolution le droit on peut la
démocratie en arménie le haut karabagh
est également aidé notre avis pas photo
aie aie aie à la servions 163e des
licences en fera voir liberté de la
presse et vous voudriez qu'on recompte
orange couleur jours mais c'est
impossible
alors que vous rave comme les dirigeants
du csr je vous demande à notre retour
entre ce chemin qui est celui
d'aujourd'hui
monsieur là qu'on nous a dit que j'avais
décroché il faut aujourd'hui interdite
solidarité militaire actionner de
solidarité dans le droit actuel et de
solidarité dans les principes actualité
dans les valeurs et cela passe par la
reconnaissance de la république du haut
karabagh comme mourad papazian jeudi en
plein essor
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
déjà voilà voilà
chatel j'ai repris tout sens
d'accueillir mamans d'allaiter variant
député du rhône
[Applaudissements]
chère amy pond soir j'étais tout à
l'heure a réussi je me suis adressé à la
représentation nationale face aux
évènements dramatiques que vivre
l'arménie l'aca bien incarner donc
ministre des affaires étrangères j'ai
posé une question au gouvernement sur la
situation en attaque et sur la nécessité
pour la france de sortir de la
neutralité pour protéger les civils et
assurer la stabilité on regarde la
réponse du vice
des affaires étrangères est inacceptable
je voudrais ce soir je n'ai pas pu me
faire une faveur dans l'hémicycle d'y
répondre devant vous monsieur le
ministre c'est pâques où il ne respecte
pas le goût de me quentin source ni
délibérément à encourir la fois pour
régler le sort des arméniens data c'est
pas cool qui n'avait fait que paul houde
domine en quittant la table des
négociations
monsieur le ministre il n'y a plus de
cesser ce samedi dernier de cesser le
feu allumé quelques heures il n'y avait
pas de train ni même
la première russe de ce qui est dû à une
trêve c'est pas là a connu les pires
bombardements de son histoire
j ai fait l'an dernier avec le cerd
entier france par sa ont maintenant avec
une délégation des parlementaires
les reportages que je vois aujourd'hui à
la télévision son horrible je le répète
plus la ville la ville et à feu la ville
ait un sens
monsieur le ministre écoutez le
président de la république ni maria emma
comme l'aurait dit que la norvégien est
responsable depuis 15 ans filles etc
avec la turquie
ils ont franchi une ligne rouge la
situation est tout simplement n'est pas
l'us ivry la sécurité
l'acteur est abaissée de manière de
gamme la partialité
ces deux les phases ils ont fait l'ufal
d'art construit ici chaque jour nous
reste et ne soit à la justice c'est
avoir choisi son corps l'a tancé ses
souvenirs l'injecteur c'est le protéger
surtout quand les populations civiles
sont quotidiennement ciblées et
actionner pour donner aux arméniens dax
à un ami il faut un essaim invicta qui
les protègent et seule la république ars
à lille et rigobert prévert
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà en tous sens proposé lui
aujourd'hui prétendre soutenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
ouais
[Applaudissements]
d'accueillir madame ne prend pas
[Musique]
je suis concerné d'être encore allez
vous ce soir pour enfants encore dénoncé
l'ignominie de la version est de la
turquie
tout à l'heure d'aller viser
ce que nous étions ensemble au cabba il
y a quelques mois et je lui disais en
aparté que j'entendais mon masque bras
je lui disais en aparté que je regardais
les photos nous avions lui à ses fans à
coeur à sushis en demandant qu'ils
étaient devenus tous ces visages
souriant s'élançant qu'il chantait ces
personnes qui vous allez accueilli avec
autant de chaleur et depuis sept jours
soit vous n'y a pas un moment que vous
je ne pense pas que ça sera la semaine
dernière c'était les derniers moments à
l'assemblée nationale est ma dernière
question gouvernement j'ai tenu à la
pause et je remercie
damien mas de l'avant permis de faire
sur le haut-karabagh 2 1
je posais ma première session
gouvernement au sénat sur le
haut-karabagh à la demande de bruno
retailleau
merci
j'ai eu président du sénat gérard
larcher au président de la commission
des affaires étrangères du sénat pour
lui demander que enceinte
le parlement français accepte la
création d'un look des cultes sur le
haut-karabagh j'ai demandé également que
le gouvernement devant au préfet qu'ils
insistent auprès des maires pour que les
charte d'amitié soit signé et soins
sélective des gestes
c est donc bien notice par rapport à la
situation gravissime qui se passe là bas
mais nous sommes parlementaire et la
diplomatie parlementaire ça existe aussi
et je pense que ce serait un signal
forme un signal important d'un nez
bicycle enfin reconnaissent ce pays
démocratique et reconnaissent le haut
karabagh aujourd'hui il ya une urgence
humanitaire et partout dans le monde je
vois qu'il ya des manifestations c'est
de los angeles le lait chaud bravo
il y avait
[Applaudissements]
on y organiser très belle manifestation
à montréal également aujourd'hui en ce
sens je pense qu'il est absolument
nécessaire que les paroles du président
ma course 3 use en avant d'aller la
raison le groupe de vince c'est pas tout
aujourd'hui tout aussi posé la question
de la turquie dans le temps on ne peut
plus considérer on fait de plus en plus
il savoir
on repère ce n'est plus possible avant
la tuerie qui narre 2 millions au ps
avec ce bateau dans les eaux
territoriales avec le franchissement
avec le temps j'ai manqué la grèce par
militaires turcs avec l'occupation de
chypre depuis 1974
il ne l'est pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
possible et il est vraiment nécessaire
que nous soyons tous unis pour demander
au gouvernement français de rontaunay ne
reconnaître larissa de demander
effectivement que les troupes
internationales de paix se met dans ce
pays n'est pas possible que ce soit le
seul son site ni coupe du monde on est
arrivé avec les avalanches de temps
c'est pourquoi celui de l'art ça
n'avance pas aujourd'hui regardez plus
ensuite parce qu'ils avaient tous dit
donc je peux vous assurer que moi mais
les loyers du garage et puis vient de
prendre ses fonctions à la cantine
là également nous sommes unis à
marseille à lyon ailleurs partout à
paris parce que je vois des visages ali
de parlementaires tous bords confondus
nazi aujourd'hui elle est importante
mais ce qui est important choix c'est ce
que nous allons faire chacun sur le
territoire souverain c'est chaka même
temps d'autres familles pour leur faire
comprendre que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est une attaque terroriste
fille nathalie ellis contre un peuple ne
demande qu'à vivre tranquillement sur
ses terres ancestrales contre les
personnes ou à l'autre bout du monde dit
sans vouloir convertir tout ce soir
oui
tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
les arméniens du haut karabagh comme les
arméniens par sa qualité d'autorité
bref tout simplement attaché à l'asie et
ses villages de voulons protéger
donc on va faire ce qu'on peut en tant
que parlementaire s'est par contre le
père de plus je me sens pension
contravention de faire de plus mais a
pas posé des questions à par harceler le
gouvernement aujourd'hui a précisé aussi
les parlementaires européens par tous
deux sont français a martelé devant nord
au niveau de l'union européenne
également le même plan se fasse pour
demander la reconnaissance au travail
surtout la protection de la vie là bas
merci
oui
gérer
[Applaudissements]
cesari en rien mes frères vous n'êtes
plus en plus nombreux au fil des
semaines va tout série de prestations
vous pouvez être fiers de vous faire car
vous êtes un pur d'efforts vos frères
qui se bat pour la liberté pour les
repas si pour le croisic chez 2000 se
bat aussi pour nous si la carte au
ménisque ont relevé eric dur les algérie
joe borg d'euros c'est ça qui te jour
des concours pour vous nous n'avons plus
de la capacité des européens à voir ce
qui se passe comme ils ont été
incapables en 1900 tél je comprend ce
qui se passait oui chance et qu'on après
air total derrière et c'est de terminer
le travail foncier en 1915 mignon mini
series of poker
alors il faut faire pression valérie les
m21 wallonie oui nous allons être
certains autres l'aspect prochain à
partir de 10h au siège athénien des
parlementaires français à prévoir
nous irons à la fin pour piloter car des
fioles
vous pouvez pas rester
[Applaudissements]
des voyages ce voyage mais aussi n'ayez
de mettre les choses sur notre
gouvernement
j'offre les comptes des pneus ainsi d'un
gain de crise et la réponse du ministre
des affaires étrangères italien n'était
pas l'auteur de l'histoire
oui nous allons aussi d'avoir mondiale
pense qu'elle doit d'être le premier
pays européen à reconnaître la ksa
cet honneur et s'il faut pour cela
pis elle construit des tours accomplis
d
les craintes et ça suffit s'il avait
fallu tgb s'est ralliée voilà qui sont
le propre et lisse
beaucoup ont terminé pour l'acsa mais il
faut aussi le gagner pour le garder
alors ce combat nous avons révélé
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
liz taylor
le franc n'a refusé
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien lorsque erdogan a soutenu les
services en lien et en syrie l'ancien
déstabiliser ces régions lancement les
chrétiens dans ces régions dont les
arméniens se sont retrouvés sur les
routes car lorsqu'il a envoyé des armes
dont ils avaient remis leurs racines de
metrol lancy permettait à d s'il ya un
risque de les rejoindre là-bas
verrons nous fait nous avons sorti la
tête l'envié de faire qui regagne nous a
envoyé des migrants
lorsqu'aucun nous pas fait un chantage
avons fait nous lui avons versé
plusieurs milliards d'euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des états unis la lybie l'algérie mon
soin sonia menace les deux pays tous
sont chers ils ont les réserves p1
je pense notamment à l'est et asie
qu'est ce que nous faisons nous avons
aujourd'hui affronter un défi cancale
aujourd'hui envoie des terroristes des
zizanies les mains les paumes yathrib
notre humanité dans rambo riant erdogan
est divine elle bond pour l'humanité
ça va et je crois la cour pénale
internationale
[Applaudissements]
oubliez vos frères d'orient jeu mais
c'est mon petit appart mais si par
d'accord bien sûr un brouillard danger
de faire des soldats désarmés
et qui a débouché pour leurs maisons qui
ont terminé de lance annie qui ont été
exécutés parce qu'aucun souvenez les
abris et aujourd'hui les 6 et 20 ça
c'est des arméniens du haut-karabakh
alors oui sa place sa place n'est pas en
europe il faut être jugé et ce n'est pas
la matière sont ici il faut exiger que
l'union européenne cessent toute
négociation doré
[Applaudissements]
là
nulle part dans l'eau il faut cesser un
milliard d'euros tous les ans c'est une
négociation est organisée par le robien
ils vont également certain de reprendre
de la force
il faut qu'il y ait des sanctions
économiques et janvier des zones cyclone
est passé lego train de se lancer par
son nationalisme pur
en sueur qui ont fait oublier de décider
que la crise économique n'est pas parce
qu'un gouvernement reconduit à la tête
de la sortie et ce pendant une manche de
nos vies et qu'elles ont ressenti
aidés par les états unis et la beauté
ira à deux fois avant de continuer dans
ce livre les taux pas maintenant
[Applaudissements]
je viens
j'ai réservé aux 4 ans et j'espère
stepan arrière juste après la chute de
charles vial est une banque d'affaires
messier touche arverne partenaires des
femmes des enfants des filles car
étaient dans la rue et que nous les
avions ont atterri et bien les avions à
ces parcelles
[Applaudissements]
hier
ils ont envahi les bords à l'ancienne et
lebron à tonga elle me manquera qu on
assassine et des arméniens par ci
détermine un patron voulait appliquer
les invasions cardy nation notée
internationale aujourd'hui nous avons
aujourd'hui
pato des dictateurs qui se sont unis
exigent de haut niveau faire disparaître
ou à des arméniens je me souviens que
certains s'étaient arménienne dans l'eau
car bar avec la sexy par les astéries
ambiance de folie dossier ils n'ont
jamais des mots clés c'étaient des
excuses mais il fallait prouver qu'ils
étaient là avant les arméniens mais le
haut karabagh a toujours les terminer
j'arrêtais le foyer national arménien m
moussavi lors toujours émerveillé
[Applaudissements]
ça
à
ah ah
quoi
à
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir pour theolia sénateur de seine
et je viens je viens vous témoigner ma
totale solidarité
la turquie a décidé de faire d'armes des
tubes en syrie lâchement nous avons de
ses fers mature qui sort aujourd'hui
dans les eaux territoriales que chip est
lâchement nous laissons faire mature qui
intervient militairement en libye
à l'aide des supplétifs de neige et
lâchement nous laissons faire la turquie
mène une politique de guerre contre la
grèce en méditerranée orientale et
lâchement nous laissons faire nature
attac l'adsa avec les mêmes supplétifs
de dèche et lâchement nous laissons
faire juste faire quand on est selon
nous la turquie devait être un peu et
elle sent le gros chariot et le caucase
ça c'est dit
[Applaudissements]
ce soit ce soir chers amis je pense à ma
nation aux poètes à l'homme dans la
famille a été tuée par le génocide de
1915 à l'homme qu'il fallait à marseille
est arrivé en région parisienne en 1940
et qui aussitôt a pris le chemin de la
résistance du combat contre l'occupant
nazi s'étonne je connaissais bien
c'était un compagnon d'armes de
mouvements père le colonel en bail ya
donné sa vie pour la force
il a été désigné au mac/val est rien
nous n'oublions pas nous n'oublions pas
[Musique]
force est réalisée pour notre libération
aujourd'hui je vous laisse de bons temps
réel c'est normal et le témoignage de
reconnaissance pour tout peuple arménien
c'est pour cette raison que l'on passé
mon parti ce mardi comme le dispensait a
reconnu officiellement la république
ball-trap c'est le premier parti du
ballon
je demande seulement ce soir tous les
partis politiques français d'en faire de
même que tous les phares qui passe bien
ils reconnaissent l'indépendance pour
que nous voir
dans une autre scène avec mes collègues
sénateurs de zèle demain nous écrirons à
tous les maires de seine pour qu'il
prenne en conseil municipal
délibération demandant à la france la
reconnaissance officielle de l'alsace
vous avez classique
bon parlementaire au maire aux élus de
toutes couleurs politiques ont-ils vaste
les choses une branche à leur montre ce
pays qui ont demandé la reconnaissance
officielle de l'adsa aujourd'hui c'est
une nécessité vitale pour éviter un
nouveau génocide
10 places à dire la vérité
[Applaudissements]
oh
rien
à
à temps
la source est simplement un combat
parole monsieur déposé nicolas geay
campagne
je voudrais le paillon et je voudrais
juste vous dire d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est une question d'honneur
de dignité c'est l'esprit de la france
liberté et honte d'avoir honte honte de
ce qui se passe
vous savez ce que vous attendez se
tourna les paroles de notre part ce sont
des actes de la france gère toi les arcs
de la france c'est qu'on s'est
simplement de se coucher devant air de
gamme
erdogan matin querry kurdes qui avaient
lutté contre des ch et redevient envoyer
des terroristes en libye avec des
conséquences incalculables sur l'afrique
avec eux nos soldats qui se battent
contre les dévents vie somani
terre-neuvienne a fait du chantage à
l'europe et eneurope acr logan en lui
donnant de l'argent des milliards
d'euros erdogan manaf la grèce les eaux
territoriales l'air de galles aucune
chute la culture gucci et nous qu'est ce
que nous faisons nous regardons ailleurs
c'est ça la réalité le gros de miss
c'est un alibi
c'est la vie pour la puissance s'est
animé pour une fausse neutralité c'est
la libye pour laisser massacrer nos amis
les arméniens
devant nous sans rien dire c'est ça la
réalité
alors oui reconnaissance bien sûr mais
des actes d arc pour la france on
retrouve sa dignité aux côtés de l'armée
et je veux vous le dire de toutes mes
forces
on ne peut pas laisser faire ça et ça
fait trop d'années qu'on laisse faire
cela et à un moment il va falloir que
déléguer à un moment il va falloir
bouger on peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est le nord de la france et d'avoir de
l'arménie ni l'arménie
dutil
voilà
j
je suis je dit oui
je suis
[Applaudissements]
ça va toujours aux côtés du peuple
mais ce député qui va bien merci
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un ami depuis 17 jours
j'ai une pensée pour tous ces soldats
ces femmes ces hommes ces enfants qui
sont massacrés par la politique
expansionniste vert de galles italienne
j'avais doublé sans jamais lui allant
nous étions avec les parlementaires de
tous bords gauche droite sens en attaque
avec va y aller avec des ailes à
laitière avec de très nombreux
parlementaires nous étions là pour celui
celles et ceux qui font vivre le
patrimoine arménien la culture
arménienne en arsac de berry en cédant
la perte saluer celles et ceux qui font
vivre le coach a remis dans les plaines
de l'artois et et d'harmonie
saluer celles et ceux qui font vivre la
démocratie en arménie et en larzac
nous étions là pour leur dire notre
fierté fierté d'être le parlementaire
français pour défendre la première des
valeurs de notre république
majid ap
et ô combien en veine elle la liberté
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes et
c'est ce que je souhaite par dessus tout
au peuple de la plagne qui puisse
disposer de sa propre liberté
nous étions là aussi pour véhiculer un
message d'espérance une vertu d'une
nature que rien n'est jamais perdu à
moteur qui permet d'avancer avec
optimisme malgré la guerre malgré les
combats devaient toujours avec franche
du collier d'autres parlementaires
l'ampleur de tout bord nous serons là en
arménie je vais faire en attaque pour
apporter notre soutien le fujian france
partisans de tous les parlementaires
tels que soit leur parti politique quel
que soit leur sensibilité bon soutenir
le bain de la mer et un pompier
dans le monde il a le mandat
il
et il y a
[Applaudissements]
il n'oubliera jamais les eaux de la
gloire de marc est venu il a vu le
cycliste toujours dans les raisons
d'hésiter à l'heure obscures
vive la france vive la république lille
a béni et les attaques
[Applaudissements]
il ya dix jours je devais parlementaire
marion parce qu'ils accumulent el paso
l'arménie et toner dans votre coeur avec
nos amis arméniens que ceux qui foi et
mon histoire telle offre commune avenue
cabrol 1
et l'histoire à caen plaide est ce que
je voudrais vous dire pas preneur et
sauf le mardi
avec la ligue et elle était gel par la
main vert dans les premiers pas à vous
donner
évidemment pour défendre et pour poser
la question du gouvernement iphone via
qu'un jour on s'est également tassé
certains c'était groupe 2005 mais a mis
depuis en croatie face et un soleil se
sont pas les rayons le suspect lui a pas
glissé qu'il a dû récemment c'est la
jeunesse arménienne qui est tué
c'est l'image que l'on poinçon ce n'est
pas possible la réponse aujourd'hui
qu'elle a été faite à ma collègue
parlementaire qui a posé deux questions
la réponse n'était pas l'auteur
le groupe de vie morale il faut
aujourd'hui la mort mêlées sans cesse
le hasard
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
quoi
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez déjà vu à décoller
gervais mont saint lô
pour vincent bouchard
[Applaudissements]
je sois les gens pour les refaire à mots
couverts de liberté au père de résister
et je vous avertis si je nous reverser
leur signalisation des milliers de fois
pour venir nous réveiller
la patrie des droits de l'homme et des
citoyens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je réveiller le peuple qui le premier
serait rassuré votre combat est une
magnifique boîte comparateur la villette
à remporter
population vivant que je suis venu tard
de poids chez vous j'y reviens
bon pied alors d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
aulas
[Applaudissements]
non
j
[Applaudissements]
au bahreïn
je fais
nouveau
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas obama
mais vous avez une chance la situation
est extrêmement critique
les appels que nous lançons à la colonne
est de ceux là ce ne sont pas mes apps
est factice
nous ne faisons pas nous ne faisons pas
semblant peut lancer des appels au
secours
fin de la sortie et les gains nice nous
ne savons pas combien de temps nous
pourrons tenir alors nous étions ya dix
jours à cet âge d'or des sciences pour
condamner désolé vous vous en souvenez
nous étions jeudi dernier devant
l'ambassade de turquie pour condamner
l'application n'est ni dans cette pièce
pour vous à retourner
chevy nous est là fait trôner nous
l'avons essayé de sens qu'aujourd'hui
nous formions plus nombreux mais vous
vous en souvenez
[Applaudissements]
je reconnais qu'on va t'arriver
et c'est arrivé
[Applaudissements]
nous nous voulons la faire là bas
alerter
boulo la déportation
de savourer leur beauté
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas complet en l'est aujourd'hui
mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup dernière on
vous a demandé si vous étiez d'accord
pour construire ici si aujourd'hui en
mobilisant chaque agent surtout ni
personne ne vous en souvenez
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous le vend ainsi que vous
êtes d'accord pour que mardi prochain
nous revenons ici
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
à
je taille
certaines mardi prochain elle de chacun
d'entre vous vous pouvez innovateur
j'espère
vous vous m'amusez issos certains pour
trouver la raison
opéra si gbagbo est incertaine
nous avons faim nous nous pencherons ne
savent pas si leur à ne pas se rendre
nous n'avons pas communauté
internationale sera pas respectée de la
dame et de la courtine mais au delà nous
si demain
pourquoi demander au président de la
république est une et lakro
[Applaudissements]
et il a tort
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
aux parlementaires une seule arme ne
sont pas encore partis en arménie orale
à la haye ne vous entre parties à venir
nous rejoindre
oui
[Applaudissements]
moi qui si marty vous nos parlementaires
phu quy nhon représenter est-ce que vous
êtes allé voir le président de la
république méthodes gros
[Applaudissements]
équipes ont assez
aulas
m
ah ah
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
ouais
à
ouah
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ouais
à
voià
1988 nous devons rentrer les enfants
nous avons la renaissance est
aujourd'hui courant aux vaches à tout
[Applaudissements]
pour la fin la musique symbole de ces
moments
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
ras
pas
ouais
chers amis vous savez dans le passé
lorsque son mari malheureusement les
deux balles ils savent à quoi nous
arméniens et de weissach à tout le monde
sa direction
[Applaudissements]
y apparaissent
sous la barre d'aller vers nos dessous
la balle est un novice c
le mistral
[Musique]
je vais continuer en français parce que
je suis certaine tout le monde je ne
crois pas compris pourtant je parle à
rien parce que mes grands parents sont
des dealers listening et arménien je
suis né arménienne en grèce et il y en a
parmi vous j'en suis certaine parce que
j'avais rencontrée au moment où j'étais
en train de venir ici et à tout prix la
manifestation auquel j'ai participé
débutants relève auprès de vous pour la
reconnaissance du génocide arménien est
aujourd'hui pour la reconnaissance d'un
talent qui est quelque chose de
parfaitement elle dispose à cet immonde
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est du
monde 6 passes depuis un certain temps
déjà
vous savez très bien qu'il n'ya pas que
l'arménie aujourd'hui qui est blessé
dans sa chair il y à déjà 44 ans shi qui
a intéressé et qu'elle a été découpé est
là
v le coran pour sort de son territoire
aujourd'hui ces territoires c'est un
territoire européen et j ai toujours aux
vipères à l'étude est-ce que vous en
prenez quelqu'un mais bien on parle
pendant tout l'été la turquie ont piégé
avec ses amis de la brèche
je ne sais plus quand les meilleurs
pendant tout l'été à voguer sans être
dérangé sauf à régler bien sûr dans les
eaux territoriales grecques elles sont
françaises en avaient entendu parler je
crois pas j'en suis fort désolé pourtant
la france a essayé d'intervenir a essayé
d'aider la grèce
pendant cet été qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est là pour essayer de
faire reconnaître un état de droit c'est
à dire un pays
qui est enclavée dans un autre pays pas
révoltés des normes qui voulaient se
joue est divisé et contenus
et ça vous le savez beaucoup mieux que
moi je n'ai pas besoin de vous faire une
leçon d'histoire mais sachez que les
arméniens parcours ils sont chez eux et
leurs terres ancestrales avatar c'est à
eux et il faut absolument les soutenir
pour de cette rencontre de bien vivre
[Applaudissements]
le sang
entend laisser faire nous savons le
faire déjà l'an dernier car l'union
européenne à faire pression sur la grèce
pour reconnaître puis identité soit 10
cents à cernier lot de matériel pour le
pays qui est à la frontière nord de la
grèce qui s'avère aujourd'hui macédoine
du nord qu'est le comte cesson et nîmes
gard saison des slaves
on n'a rien contre les salles mais ils
ne sont pas vrai qu'ils ne sont pas
massés venir la même chose les arméniens
qui sont dans l'enclavé
l'azerbaïdjan ne sont pas les azéri même
oscille secours dans cet état
aujourd'hui s'appelle à l'impérial les
amener en le droit de réclamer si les
revenus leur patrie leur terre
ancestrale
je vous remercie et j'aimerais qu'on
continue ce combat et que vous sachiez
renault sans tous ensemble nous sommes
avec vous
il
il a rappelé
là
[Applaudissements]
pour toutes les femmes qui souffrent
pour moi et surtout la volonté pour les
centres ont et qu'ils font tous les
jours des marques héroïques ont servi
notre temps pour du très bon boulot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
ouais
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
ouais
à
[Applaudissements]
ouais
voilà
à
[Applaudissements]
m
ah ah
quoi
what
[Applaudissements]
tous
mais l'illusion d'écouter les seniors
mais les ingénieurs ils sont prêts pour
compass hier c'est la vie pour lester
estimant ne retrouver mais new scientist
et bolo sanou ne se comptent pas pour
tous
[Applaudissements]
quels héraults attendu et tapas à bord
du ferry boat big sea to sky ou b de
hockey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous mettons les choses sont nés nous
tourner le ballon passe au millième but
d'aller dîner au menu
[Applaudissements]
il passe à boyet msb mise tout sur
divers amis de gauche aurait la mairie
[Applaudissements]
cérémonie
oh
à
hu
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
d'ailleurs il ajouté
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés pc le
faisceau de la république nous sommes
français des français dans le pays
d'origine
le 10 12 ans elle a réuni se trouve un
branchement pas dicter son histoire car
c'est son existence n qui aujourd'hui
est menacée en effet comme vous le savez
derrière celle du conseiller armé par
romain alors c'est une attaque
d'envergure contre le club d'al sadd la
grille ce territoire historique roi
arménien serait le prélude à la
destruction de l'arménie alors je parle
devant les portes non loin de ses portes
de cet illustre maison qu'est
l'assemblée nationale les bombes et des
missiles
dès 10h 10 tickets le tombe sur les
populations civiles
malgré le cessez le feu les drones les
avions de guerre bomba ben non seulement
aux soldats qui vaille à l'enfant face à
l'envahisseur mais aussi à nos hôpitaux
nos centrales électriques
nos églises et monuments historiques qui
atteste de la présence millénaire du
peuple arménien ont des airs comme ça à
l'heure où je vous parle des femmes de
18 à 55 ans son rôle
bon alors que l'armée
défense sarthe chez les élus elles sont
calmes seuls est décidé au grain mon
coeur
les sionistes leur visage et pas la
guerre
parce qu'elles savent ce qui se trame
mais saab qui se tient en page 2 nous
est le seul qui n'a aucun désir c'est la
tête à l'heure où nous nous retrouvons
devant le bar devant ce bâtiment au
centre st depuis plus de 200 ans
les débats de celles et ceux qui croient
en la liberté l'égalité et surtout la
paternité est devant lui
eve à la renaissance d'un empire ottoman
ce faisant et pour définitivement le dos
à la terre et à ses engagements envers
l'europe des sérères l'asie centrale
turcophone il se dirige la fto l'origine
sa matrice et ces deux là c'est de là
qu'il comptait lancer et faire payer je
ne sais quelle offense correspondent à
ce petit monsieur jourdain est souvent
en colère est derrière cette colère il
ya une envie
regardez nos clients de son père et le
pan turquie sme est la dernière
trouvaille au plus tôt je te projet
sorti du chapeau de son derrière
démoniaque et mégalomaniaques regarder
les cartes de la région
l'arménie est un obstacle géographique à
son délire impérialistes dont on parle
bien de son homologue tayeb ou déclarent
agir quand nous disons vouloir la paix
je pense que nous sommes faits pour être
heureux
un lien couple board faire parler et une
perte de temps négocié la belle-mère les
dames et messieurs les députés entendent
et nous nous nous faisons pas trop tard
pour la renaissance d'un autre site mais
pour la renaissance d'accès libre et
indépendant
[Applaudissements]
selon les membres la maison des hommes
d'honneur à sac le droit de disposer de
telles peines il ya pas longtemps les
écossais vont décider de leur sort lors
d'un référendum
pourquoi les arméniens pourquoi les
arméniens de balsa ne réside pas le même
droit
une voix universelle sont elles à
géographie variable en 1288 au sortir de
la politique il eu d'arrivée en deçà
quant à son désir d'émancipation il a
été suivi comme vous le savez hélas le
propos anti arméniens dans les grandes
villes d'asie comme un parcours et hasna
laissez moi vous dire c'est peut-être
ligne de représentants de la rencontre
souvent des héros tiens je cite nous
avons toujours voulu être dans la
légalité jours pour le faire
nous avons attendu de 1988 l'année que
nous avons commencé
revendication jusqu'à 1280 cause pour
déclarer leur indépendance en toute
légalité
nous allons renoncer un autre avec le
plus cher nous nous réunir et à la mer
arménie pour rester dans la légalité
on nous a dit pour est audible pour être
audible des puissants de ce monde
il fallait que nous soyons porteur de
valeurs universelles et puis nous
construisions une société démocratique
c'est si nous avons fait pendant 30 ans
pour être audible des grandes nations
nous a suggéré d'attendre et l'angle
pour créer notre existence couleurs dans
mon français en anglais en espagnol
cc nous allons faire nous avons appris
des langues
nous avons grillé notre croire à
l'existence tous deux nous n'avons pas
été possible aujourd'hui mon peuple
résiste il résiste par s'il n'a pas le
choix parce s'agit une fois de plus du
droit à l'existence de haute montagne et
nous défendons nos montagnes
nous dépendons non seulement le général
nous aimons nos maisons en béton
demain soir
c'était marrant c'est que nous avons
testé le voir comment 3000 rands défense
nous apprendre aux emmys et jean
lasserre nous dépendons tous que nous
avons tous que nous avons nos montagnes
sont beaux et ap london bien le ciel les
lignes arrières d'échappatoire nous
allons donc résister et rester en vie
[Applaudissements]
au revoir
la liga sont les arméniens c'est cela
c'est de cela que l'on discute dans les
chancelleries djoko azéri ou plutôt
comment maquiller s'éteignent un
massacre un impôt légal on en a que les
gars alors vous dites que nous sommes
trop jeunes arnys voire paranoïaque
même si le président m'a conquis en
méditerranée orientale a réagi avec
panache il ya un avant goût de cette
force et ligue 2
vous ne savez rien rien n'existait
d'historique et des villes entières
nous nous à réunir du monde du monde
entier nous avons nous avons les
connaissances nous les connaissons
depuis 600 ans et sa longue et à ce
qu'ils sont capables du pire ils eurent
fait elle retrouve si l'occasion leur en
décoller leur histoire s'est construit
sur des génocides les basses des mazades
et les nettoyages ethniques
or alors de la population humaine
toujours nier in hawaii invité les nerfs
du crime les kurdes les grecs et
chypriotes
à lévis les assyro chaldéens ne le
savent que trop d'autre part ont disparu
si les turcs et ne sont plus là pour en
témoigner
mais là j'ai les yeux le député on ne
retouche pas une armée de tueurs avec
des mesures
nous savons qu'il nous le savons sont
toujours en retard d'un massacre serait
de nos lois et de nos valeurs ils se
fichent de l'open de l'onu contrairement
à la guerre froide
ce début d'une histoire d'un bloc contre
un autre mais d'une confrontation de
civilisation d'un côté au journalisme
conquérant salchaud cours de gym
haussière mais la crise de savolles
peloton
le lendemain
n'oublie pas de se construire la
démocratie les alliances contre nature
rendre caduques les schémas
transatlantique
il a aidé le sénat thallion prend les
devants ces bandes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est drôle le seul ne se souvenait pas
de facto l'un du pakistan 10 cadrés de
bakou doha
et si je me trompe et le prix le plus
gentil cellules qu'ils soient ne sont
elles pas un allié de la turquie dès
lors un deal à owni et qui a pour nouvel
ennemi
john allen et n'ya plus récents gradins
dispenser des votes qui a basculé dans
le camp des nationalismes même testé ce
message d'espoir il est important d
arméniens je me les kurdes ou celui des
cils il passe à cette acuité déontologie
à ce raisonnement binaire et un moral
s'oppose la verticalité des takfiristes
c'était un hommage unanime ce nouveau
gène isère il les paie cette métisse
étendant leur part mais la véritable
lydia 10 à 10 c'est lui c'est lui qui
rase des bardes et en voir nos remis la
vie de la vie les brigades et
internationale de la haye de la mort
c'est lui qui les envoie en six telekurs
qui nous avons contre eux soient
abandonnées fort de cette hésitation
galles le vendredi saint en payant et
harmonie terroristes allaient arrêter un
drame aux naines ont fermé les portes du
dialogue sont deux le temps de la parole
est désormais caduque pour ses tenues
des millionnaires l'époque du sel et du
pain aironi
ce sont des analystes des antilles vers
des 10 l'espagne 200 dhs de la crau
m
[Applaudissements]
des chars clément facettes de nos
confidences sur cette neige sur cette
éternité par le sang de nos héros ils ne
veulent rien entendre ni raison ni
logique ni preuves irréfutables veulent
la guerre alors comment parler et
pourquoi donc
un des piliers de cette grande nation du
lancement 1915
nous irions dans les îles de la grande
histoire nous oublie cette offre je vous
le dis n'allez pas vous perdre dans le
registre du train si promise il n'y a
pas de morale ni l'ombre génétique chez
ces deux hommes
pourquoi s'entêter à être d'être avec
deux manettes pour risque d'entraîner le
monde dans la guerre ces deux dictateurs
s'accrochent des essais les râles
pouvoir
que nous reste-t-il quel langage à noter
le courage et la fermeté politique je
vous demande donc solennellement de
reconnaître l'indépendance de la star
bat toi
[Applaudissements]
voir je vais laisser le brésil
française parfois c'est en coinçant sont
priés de l'embrasure jeu l'on croise la
force du destin et que mon nom dans la
gorge du soir hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
temps
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
à
ça
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
très
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis je si haut
oui
non monsieur réalisateur robert t
quels sont les points que vous terminiez
quels seront les bois les propos de noël
arménien de cette manière de lier et du
monde entier
on voudrait les faire taire on voudrait
les mettre à terre vous vous trompez
shirts en isère vous vous trompez
mesdames messieurs les députés il y a
en 1996 un jeune député de 37 ans il
s'appelait jean jaurès qui danse elle
l'assemblée nationale a porté devant les
ministres de l'époque un ministre
corrompu la question arménienne en
disant vous accusez les impérialistes
les agitateurs et des responsables des
deux cent mille morts commis bassoul
thon rouge at il admis et aujourd'hui
sauf mon oeil
ça
pourquoi pas question parution
restera oui mesdames et messieurs
l'hypocrisie diplomatique comme leur
anglais simon abkarian doit être
terminée aujourd'hui ce sont des actes
et des actes forts dont nous avons
besoin ne verront pas besoin
commisération
nous avons besoin d'actes forts avons
besoin de guerre le natif et pas d'entre
eux mais diplomatique
je la veux dire je dois dire beaucoup
d'entre vous j'ai du mal à trouver le
sommeil
je dois vous dire que des photos les
souvenirs des parents des grands parents
du génocide
rencontre avec force mais rappelons
cette histoire le génocide de 1915 a été
précédé par un premier génocide celui
des 194 à la française a manqué
hautement personne n'a rien dit
heureusement que j'ai eu une jeunesse
heureuse manqué ni les manceaux
heureusement que le france pour être
défenseur ici en france
et oui avec l'académie
puis on apprend aujourd'hui déserte oui
reconnaissance reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]
à
oui
c'est plus sympa
avec nantes eh oui monsieur le président
emmanuel macron vous êtes un beau père
et ses soeurs d'une certaine manière à
la ville au fil de ce soir monsieur
mitterand qui
alors que une loi n'est pas été votée
parler du génocide arménien que ce soit
le président jacques chirac
j'ai reconnu la loi qui a signé cette
fois de mieux que déclarative
reconnaissance j'ai récité désarmement
clients demain et puis da tentative de
franchir le horn est d'abord de nicolas
sarkozy et de neruda sa cause et après
pour porter les noirs 1 infligeant aux
négationnistes
1 et bien c'est le président là
messieurs sont l'honneur monsieur wagon
de la france
vous devez être à la hauteur de cette
situation mais dans cette situation
c'est reconnaître ça c'est le rôle
cette europe
merkel cette europe ne peut plus vivre
ne peut tenir aux gens tant avec dans sa
cave lequel un monoplace à signer ça ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est pas possible
non de [ __ ] aurait la tête ils peuvent
regarder pour voir une histoire qui se
déroule et c'est qu'ils se diront en ce
moment c'est l'histoire d'un peuple qui
veut passer et anéantir qui lui pas à
pas sur ses terres ancestrales pour que
le tueur sanguinaire ne donne pas la
démentir
et oui il faut pour sauver ce peuple de
l'inde et commence son indépendance
l'accent connu renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci
oh
l année
bien dans pour la musique et puis un
temps pour les tambours de guerre
plus tôt la musique tout ce que j'aime
moi j'ai découvert la musique de 205
hier pas si longtemps que ça
j'ai découvert la poubelle logiquement
qu'ils soient et quand j'étais en
arménie quand j'étais à yerevan il ya
des encore et j'ai visité évidemment le
musée du génocide
et là j'ai été frappée par les photos ça
n'était pas des photos d'eux des troupes
et comme on a l'habitude de voir avec
des seuls nature ça n'était pas les
misérables les enfants marion
l'escalette humain c'était les photos de
jeunes filles carré des diplômes
d'université
celle des photos de l'arménie et des
arméniens qui vivait dans les villes de
turquie et qui était magnifique avait
des jeunes hommes étaient en tenue de
golf y avait de jazz band tt on était
des gens brillants et c'est la première
fois que je me suis dit dès les ancêtres
était autre chose que les réfugiés de
marcher à quatre pattes
et puis pousser de l'herbe comme accro
mais on a arrangé
moi je croyais que j'étais issu de gens
misérables
or j'étais issu de gens qui étaient
encore une fois cultivée qui étaient mes
musiques et des savants et toutes les
lignes arrières
[Applaudissements]
et
si m
[Applaudissements]
seuls des riches de notre peuple en
idées en tant que survivant monde et
dégaine ils ont dix sept cent quatre
coins du monde
manque de bol c'est qu'on s'attaque
dégaine
voilà
alors que son oncle vernon à notre
niveau ici en france bien au chaud
on peut faire ce qu'on peut faire chacun
à son attente à lens le dr le mien c'est
courir ma gueule de tordre en temps ça
fait plaisir de parler d'autre chose que
de la douane le smiaa télévision pas
doublé 10 ans m'a demandé d'intervenir
j'étais une lettre au président r de
galles j'ai réclamé le patron de ma
grand-mère et 30 machines à côte
forestière 20
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
ils nous envoient des prix relève et je
suis sûr que les gens mieux vaut changer
maintenant
j'étais là-bas ça bouge et jovica aussi
70 mille arméniens qui sont à l'histoire
bull alors coface et russes qui nous
avaient investi pour des titres thétys
michel gaborit pentagone est viscéral
loukoum et ben [ __ ] on voyage coûte de
la grand mère c'est toujours ça je
chose on essaie derrière son but mais
voilà il est important autant là on est
important comme on est nombreux ya une
haine steam à un poste qui m'a
bouleversé
chacun que je vois elle s'appelle élise
boghossian la première fois qu'elle m'a
demandé de témoigner pour elle parce
qu'elle a créé une fondation qui
s'appelle et visière est la concurrence
irish aidé à l'expo et les imaginer des
uns n'est pas marrant elle a réussi à
récolter beaucoup d'argent n'a pas
beaucoup plus que ça et je n'ai vu
d'être son impératrice dans la crau et
deux jours après elle m'envoyait impose
en disant je suis dans une case zéro lag
est on a quatre macase partager et elle
y est allé tout seul
voilà qu'on joue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle histoire
allez
[Applaudissements]
à
enfin moi je sais de par alien c'est
vrai qu'il est très touchée pouvoir les
pour le voir être ludique chirac parce
que la musique je sois en série b g et
sur l'île
merci mais ce que je dis
d'abord chez
[Musique]
c'est incroyable parce que vous avez
ces glaciers du matin au soir
ça prend pas comment c'est possible
c'est chez moi on est en train de
bombarder nous on n'a rien fait on n'a
jamais voulu plus on a toujours resté
sur mon territoire et jamais
mais j'avais un peu envahissant a
toujours été simple et la joie y est
tous ces gens dans les cas en train
d'essayer de survivre beaucoup de s'il
en est extrait david avec un réseau
formidable de bénévoles avec des réseaux
facebook qui vont à la frontière
chercher des familles les femmes et des
enfants une longue de tous les hommes
sont mobilisés pour aller sur le tronc
et puis une fois arrivé à voler sous
loyers émane la favec toujours sur
l'hérault facebook tous ces jeunes super
engagés chaque famille problème l'été à
disposition son appartement
et puis et qu'elle allait régis sa
belle-mère jeu search faire en tout cas
toutes les familles qui arrivait et
quelques unités moi qui ai l'habitude de
voir des conneries fléchi blindés
remplir en plus partout à ras bord dans
tous les camps jeunes et là j'avais une
seule personne dormir dans la rue ça
passe et son fils
vraiment les touareg
la main
partage son frigo n'importe quoi sauf à
new delhi partagent tout et ça c'est
notre force
je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
montre à tout le monde parce que comme
ça qu'on va gagner au monde où le groupe
n'a rien soins peuvent de fait preuve
d'amour et que finalement c'est la peur
l'accord qui est l'ennemi de l'amour et
je pense que si on déteste as pensé
parce qu'on est meurt d'amour voilà
je voulais juste dire un gros nicolas a
d'abord est là avec gina
toronto les mobiliser je pense qu'il n'y
a pas un seul français d'origine
arménienne charles était content comme
ça ils disaient ils disaient on n'est
pas les arrières france on est des
français d'origines impayés elle en a
deux josiane idée 100% concept 100%
manière légale
[Applaudissements]
nausées
et voilà
mais bon
[Applaudissements]
à
nous savons aussi servir à l'achat mais
prochainement grâce à séné qui chante
sur le ballon mais nous sommes un cran
au dessus yvan attention et vous pouviez
l'oise ont fait tourner la tête mais
trophy price méritait d'être avec mes
l'hélico qui est sans nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
ja
5à s'impose mais savait car on le sait
le rôle mais sans trop élevé des
paillettes mais à sa décharge il s make
up et la route ya rayeh mail et par les
lignes ouaouicha
yann sommer et facebook
rona à la mairie de mulhouse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
retrouvez ce coup mais cette fois il est
fasciné
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
à
il est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons aujourd'hui la démonstration
de 13 communes isation avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et lignée des
milliers de personnes rassemblées ici
devant l'assemblée nationale pour
demander la reconnaissance de l'arrêt
technique durant la part de la star par
la france nous avons eu beaucoup de
parlementaires
beaucoup d'élus merci à eux mais nous
sommes ici rassemblés à paris mais ce
n'est pas nouveau en soutien à law frère
alain soeur 1 au sonar qui dépend notre
cher votre les filles atterri entre les
nuits cure et nous devons continuer et
rené alors on a fait la promesse est
alors l'arrivée pas se disperser mardi
prochain sera
[Musique]
si vous avez
[Applaudissements]
relais
combattre ou bien alors elle sert de
rien à voir jusqu'au bout parce que nous
nous faisons rien
tout est bien
là
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
voilà
mais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
e
j'ai un ami je vous ferai mon pour vous
remercier et remercier tous les élus qui
ont pris la parole à cette tribune
tous ceux qui vont manifester leur
solidarité et leur soutien pour ne pas
terminer sur une note pessimiste
en ces moments difficiles
en effet nous voyons des gens de mourir
sur la ligne de front
je voudrais revenir surtout que nous
voyons ensemble ce pape et des jeunes se
bat sur les deux fronts et que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
il enregistre des victoires est l'une
des victoires il y à 50 ans le peuple
américain s'est levé et il a intégré au
monde que le temps était révolue où les
arméniens se laisse pas sacré a ruiné
mans
cette motion nous continuons à défendre
et à l'assumer
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus
un pop de nous devons rien intentions de
gentilles et irait aux réfugiés
nous sommes aujourd'hui un état nous
avons deux républiques
nous avons une abeille nous allons faire
soir nous avons compris surtout que nous
nous devions et que nous ne pouvions
compter que sur nos propres forces et
merci pour chargement demande avec moi à
l'invasion avec lendemain du ceser et
plantes aux organisations de rester
mobilisés étaient présents mardi
prochain et s'il est devant l'assemblée
nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
c'est
mais je
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
à
[Applaudissements]
la grappe
nous
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
m
à
[Musique]
et
là
[Applaudissements]
lorsque vous
les bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
c'est sûr
[Musique]
il ya ce que c'est
allez
il y avait
je râle
on ne l'attend pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on estompe à cet incident
ils agissent à
[Applaudissements]
oh